[Musique]
la fierté
l'émotion et la dignité de simone veil
qui est entrée aujourd'hui à l'académie
française
à 82 ans elle devient ainsi la sixième
femme à rejoindre le cercle très fermé
des immortels dans son hommage endorment
sans rappeler le parcours de cette femme
d'engagement qui a marqué le xxème
siècle par son action politique et
féministe
jean-paul girouard des roulements de
tambours des habits verts et brodé des
épées et des discours depuis 1635 c'est
comme ça sous la coupole
quand on accueille un nouveau salué le
plus souvent pour son oeuvre littéraire
aujourd'hui c'est un destin et la façon
d'y faire face que l'on a salué simone
veil elle même ne s'y trompe pas n'ayant
moi même aucune prétention littéraire
tout en considérant que la langue
française demeure le pilier majeur de
notre identité je demeure surprise et
émerveillée que vous m'ayez conviée à
partager votre combat face au président
et à doute ses prédécesseurs passer une
audience nettement plus ému qu'à
l'accoutumée ce états ont d'ormesson qui
revenu le discours d'hommages et
d'accueil
je pense avec émotion à tous ceux et à
toutes celles qui ont connu l'horreur
des camps de concentration et
d'extermination leurs souvenirs à tous
entre ici avec vous vous avez dominé ce
malheur avec une fermeté d'âme exemple
est ce que vous êtes d'abord c'est
courageuse et les français aiment le
courage comme l'immense majorité des
français nous vous aimons madame
déclaration d'amour et ovations
l'unanimité des immortels s'est
poursuivie jusqu'à la forte elle va
apporter de la hauteur de l'expérience
du rappel de principe de l'indépendance
ce qui est
il est nécessaire de temps en temps
simon nouvelle n'est que la sixième
femme académicienne dans cette enceinte
aussi elle aura à coeur l'élargir la
brèche
[Musique]